ayem a agité les réseaux comme mon ami
parce qu'elle a posté une photo d'elle
et sans déconner je lis allait quand
même je vois là l'haïtien c'est la photo
qu'elle a mise à les en a pas mal à bien
le ventre il est tout plat
ouais j'ai dû mettre comme ça en fait
et alors et alors et alors là c'est
magnifique elle rien polémique parce que
à huy opus et pop la prière plus à
l'abri de l'oseille parce qu'elle n'a
plus besoin alors je me doute bien aimé
la question est la suivante est ce que
ces retouches et photoshopée n'est bien
sûr la boîte peut-être et photoshopée
forme sur la boîte terrebonne comment
merci merci
c'est vraiment vous voulez vous c'est
vraiment la fête regardez c'est bon on a
vu où elle a compris la claque sim ce
sera c'est pas la première sera pas la
dernière
même nous lorsqu'on passe des choses sur
instagram et on met parfois quelques
filtres pour nous mettre en alors c'est
pas pareil jamais mon cv subtilité oui
en fait quoi ce que j'ai du mal à saisir
vos joueuses elle est ce que c'est une
pub pour le pour la marque de caleçons
ou pour la marque de deux classes ton
voilà les deux dames ont peut-être
qu'elle a fait coup double ouais cool
d'être vous confirme que non mais bon
ici parce que c'est un morcellement qui
palpe alors si oui alors retouché
photoshopée alors eh bien désolée de
vous décevoir mais absolument pas et
j'en ai la preuve par cas liés mais mon
ami ayem je dors avec quel jeu là sur
alors ça ça nous intéresse alors ça
alors je voudrais en savoir un double de
l'assumer
c'est la cfa moment parce que là on fait
attention mais tu es avec moi ya pas
longtemps je laisse n'allant bienvenue
et bon voyage
mais là ça n'a rien mais j'ai les sna
pays à la fin et je peux vivre en images
là pour humaine franchement maya ce
ventre plein de paillettes
qu'est ce que c'est que ce dans tout
plein de paillettes salissez bon bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre vidéo est pas mal franchement
c'est son année d'âge
désolé alors pardon mais y avait une
partie de la vidéo sur la première
partie où on voyait vraiment que c'était
bien plat parce que j'avais pris profil
mais là c'est celui ment pas ayem elle
est devenue comme ça elle fait beaucoup
beaucoup de concessions alimentaires
elle le dit qu'on se sent inventeur
beaucoup de sport elle prend
effectivement des compléments
alimentaires elle dit bien que ce n'est
pas les compléments alimentaires qui ont
fait perdre son poids c'est un
complément elle s'habille un complément
aux 4es du sport et elle a passé un mois
et demi en cure de régime mais ça j'y
crois mais toutes les femmes du monde
nouvelles cellules y tu mama gamme est
l'un des modèles à effigie on a compris
l ai pas retouché
franchement si un peu et patients
allaient bien